Okay, so pennants are really great for
representing collections that
are powers of two in size.
But a bag needs to be able to
contain any number of elements, so
how can we use pennants
in order to build bags?
And it turns out a basic idea from
computer science preschool is what is
going to help us.
First, I want you to remember a basic
fact about binary arithmetic.
In particular, you can represent any
non-negative integer as a binary string.
So, let's take an integer,
I don't know, how about 23.
How do you write this in binary?
The answer is 10111.
In base two.
Now each bit position represents
a distinct power of two,
so let's number the bit positions.
So this bit is 2 to the 0
which is equal to 1.
The second bit is 2 to the 1 or
2 and we can go on and on and on.
And notice that 16 plus
4 plus 2 plus 1 is 23.
Okay.
So, what does this have to do with bags?
Here's a collection of 23 elements.
And let's say I want to
throw them in to a bag.
How do I do it?
Here's an idea!
Let's use pennants.
So, you can see what I've done here.
In the same way that you can take the
integer 23 and write it as a series or
a sequence of powers of 2, I've taken
the items in the collection and
I've grouped them into powers of 2.
Now I'm going to need to
connect these in some way.
So to do that,
I'm going to use an array of pointers
to the roots of each pennant.
And I'll use a null pointer for
the empty bit.
Now, this array,
I'm going to give a special name.
I'm going to call it a spine.
So just as a brief recap,
I've taken my collection of elements.
I've broken it up into these
power of two sized pennants.
And I've connected them together with
this thing that I'm calling a spine